un soleil de plomb et une plage de sable
fin difficile de résister à la tentation
en période estivale les bords de lac
sont toujours pris d'assaut l'occasion
de rappeler certains gestes à adopter
pour que petit et grands puissent se
baigner en toute sécurité au plan d'eau
de l'île de loisirs des Boucles de Seine
l'assurance la Macif a organisée une
opération de prévention quel risque lié
au soleil on est déjà invité de se faire
brûler éviter de rentrer dans l'eau
directement parce que c'est très violent
il y a des risques liés à tout ce qui
est addiction divers et variées ils
prennent conscience qu'il y a des
risques et que ça devienne finalement
des réflexes au plus tard pour que ils
soient vigilants que même si on fait on
joue on fait moins attention on a quand
même quelques réflexes de type
prévention
identifier les risques du plan d'eau
connaître les bons réflexes en cas
d'accident ou encore s'initier aux
gestes de premiers secours l'objectif
était de sensibiliser les parents comme
les enfants Thomas sapeur-pompier
volontaire dans le Val-d'Oise était sur
place pour dispenser aux estivants des
notions de secourisme en alternance avec
le massage cardiaque faire après c'est
c'est deux étapes consécutives en fait
c'est un cycle ce qu'on vient de faire
30 compression il va falloir vérifier
son état de conscience c'est le plus
important dans un premier temps et
ensuite si malheureusement elle est
inconsciente ce qui risque d'être le cas
en cas de noyade prendre la respiration
et puis deux cas de figure se s'offrent
à nous heureusement elle respire il va
falloir faire en sorte qu'elle continue
à respirer donc la mettre sur le côté
puisque le danger est de mort si on la
laisse à plein d'eau et si elle ne
respire pas et bien de toute façon on va
falloir maintenir une respiration de
manière artificielle en réalisant un
massage cardiaque tout le monde devrait
être formé à ses premiers ces gestes de
premiers secours parce que ça peut
arriver en fait un accident arrive par
nature un accident on peut on sait
jamais quand ça arrive donc en cas de
situation d'urgence n'hésitez pas à
alerter le poste de secours le plus
proche ou bien composé le 15 ou le 18 en
juin 2023 233 cas de noyade dont 80
mortelles ont été recensés en France